النجمه الليله عبد الله بالطل على الجمهور
في الموسم الرمضاني هذا ببطوله عملين
الاول دفعه لندن اللي بتكون فيه بشخصيه
مضاوي طالبه بالسنه الثالثه من كليه الطب
ابوها من اغنى اغنياء الكويت وماجر
الطالبات غرف معاها في شقتها وبتكون
مداومه من البنات اللي ما يميزوا بين
الخير والشر والاستغلال والطيبه
[موسيقى]
الجدل في هذا الموسم وكنا تكلمنا عنه امس
حتى من ناحيه بعض العراقيين اللي اعتبروا
مسيء ومهين لهم لانه احدى البنات عراقيه
بتعمل خادمه وبتتهم بالسرقه هذا بالاضافه
الى كلمه معينه قالتها كمان احدى البزلات
في مشهد معين وعملت جدل واعتبروها الناس
غير لائقه وكانت ليله طلعت وردت على الجدل
حول الكلمه وقالت انه ردات الفعل كانت
نفاق مبالغ فيه وانه الكلمه ما فيها شيء
وعادي جدا وبالنسبه للجدل الاخر ما تكلمت
ليلى وقالت انه كل شيء في وقته حلو اما
العمل الثاني اللي بتقوم فيه بطولته
والمسلسل الكويتي كذبت ابريل اللي بيتكلم
عن اسره تاجر معروف على مستوى المجتمع
بيقوم بدوروا الفنان الكبير جاسم النبهان
وبتكون زوجته الفنانه الكبيره زهره عرفات
وبعيشوا في الظاهر حياه مثاليه ولكن بعد
وفاته بتكتشف تفاصيل صادمه
الافكار والاوهام اللي ببالك المريضه هذه
شيليها اول شيء يسوون حبيبتك واستغلها
هلقط ام هالقطه وحمتك بيبي اللي انت ما
تشهد الا باسمها
نفس اللعبه بس علشان تحرق قلبي انا البنيه
اللي هديتها
وقت تنضم الينا الفنانه ليلى عبد الله
اهلا فيك معانا يا ليلى وكل عام وانت بالف
خير يا رب يا اهلا يا اهلا ساره الجميله
شلونك شو اخبارك يا حبيبتي عيدي موضوع
الجميل مره ثانيه بالله
بقول لك عيدي لي موضوع الجميله عشان
الزملاء اللي بيشككوا فيها
مزهزه
ليلى خلينا نبتدي نتكلم عن بطولاتك هذه
السنه طبعا انت ما شاء الله كل سنه بتعملي
ادوار والكلام ده كله يعني كم سنه بتعملي
ادوار جدليه وماخذه وعامله الجو السنه
برضه دفعت لندن جدلي جدا كيف صرتي من
اعضاء الدفعه
اولا طبعا يعني انا الحمد لله سعيده يعني
بالنجاحات هذه اللي قاعد تصير وسعيده
وفخوره طبعا بكل طاقم العمل وكل زملائي
اهنيكم وان شاء الله بعد في الايام
القادمه راح تشوفون حلقات
يعني مهمه وجدليه اكثر وفيها رساله وفيها
فن وفيها جماليات كثيره كيف صرت اعضاء
الدفعه والله السنه اللي طافت احنا صار
لنا طبعا ثمانيه اشهر قاعد نشتغل على
المسلسل كلمتني الاستاذه هبه مشاري حماده
وقالت لي انا شايفتك في دور مضاوي واقراي
المسلسل قولي لي يعني اذا حبيتيه وبس
وصارت واشتغلنا الحمد لله طلعت لمن قرات
الورق ليلى حسيتي انه حيعمل ضجه اكيد
توقعتي
صراحه شوفي انا ما ما اتنبا للمستقبل يعني
وانا اقرا يعني للاعمال لان اكون
بحاله فنيه وايد شديده يعني اكون مندمجه
مع الادوار والشخصيات والشخوص وطبعا كنت
غرقانه في زمن الثمانينات وكان عاجبني
الكلام
والشخصيات كلها كلها حبيتها ودخلت قلبي
طبعا انت لما تقرين من واحد ل 30 متواصل
في اربعه ايام كانك تقري في روايه
دائما يعني لمن ادخل اي عمل اتنبا ليا يا
رب وادعي النجاح هذا اهم شيء عندي
الجدل ويصير ولا بتسوي ضجه بصوره مدري
شلون ما يعني مو من
اهدافي بس لا اقول لك مو من الاشياء اللي
احطها في مخي انا اهم شيء عندي النجاح
يكون للعمل طيب هو العمل ناجح طبعا بس
عامل يعني بموازات النجاح هذا في جدل
موازي لهذا النجاح وبحجم هذا النجاح لما
نجي نتكلم عن مثلا بعض الكلمات اللي قالوا
الناس اعتبروها مثلا خارجه وكذا انت حضرتك
طلعتي ودافعتي خليني بس يمكن اعرض لك كليب
صغير من كلامك اللي قلتيه بس
دائما احنا يعني مثلا احنا اغراضنا اغراض
بنات ما يصير نقول حرام عيب كل شي بالخشوه
كل شيء كذي يعني ما ينقال انا اشوف ما
ادري انا اشوفه مبالغه بالنفاق صراحه يعني
انا كل مره قاعد اشوف نفاق زياده وزياده
بطريقه خلاص اني تعبت منها انا بالنسبه
ليك ليلى انا قاعد برا الحق ولا احد انا
بالنسبه ليك ليلى انا احس انه انه اعيد مو
تبرير حق ولا احد انا احس ان الكلمه ما
فيها شيء وبدي اقول عن القضيه الثانيه
نتكلم عن النقطه الاولى ما تحسي انه من حق
الناس انهم يتحسسوا من بعض الكلمات اللي
بيعتبروها حساسه خاصه مثلا
لا
طبعا من حقهم يعني انا مو ضد ان احد يقول
رايه ولا ينتقد ولا حتى يطلع ويسب يعني
بالنهايه يعني هذا جمهور وكلامهم دائما
على عيني وعلى راسي ولا اخص بالكلام الاحد
انا دائما
اتكلم عن رايي الشخصي انا هذا رايي الشخصي
انا طبعا في يعني
بس انا بحتفظ فيه لكن انا اتكلم في نقطه
اني اشوف هذا جزء من الواقع يعني هذا كانت
قاعده بنات وكنا قاعد نتكلم عن شيء معين
وان قالت الكلمه بغض النظر صح ولا غلط لكن
انا من باب انه هذا اول شيء واقع بس قلتي
منافقين
انا ما جمعت ساره ولا خاصيت ولا يعني حددت
يعني فئه معينه لكن انا في فئه معينه في
بالي تكلمت عنها ويمكن خلني تعبير شويه
وانا اتكلم لكن كان كلامي كله
بصوره شلون اشرح لك اياها اكثر دفاعا عن
كل ما انا اشوفها واقعيه وان قالت بين
بنات
واحسها انه بالنسبه لي انا كليله انه يعني
ممكن تنقال في اطار معين درامي في سياق
يعني موضوع يخدم المشهد واشوف انه ما فيها
شيء لو انت قلتي كمان يمكن نكته في كثير
ناس بيتكلموا عنها الان بشكل عام يعني حول
العالم يعني انه قصه انه الاشياء اللي تخص
المراه يعني دائما فيه لنقولها اوبس عيب
نقولها اوبس لازم نخبيها
ايه ان الاشياء هذه انا شويه لانها يعني
خلينا نقول مع حقوق المراه يعني فاحس ان
شويه الموضوع اثارني اثارني من داخل انه
في اشياء ممكن تمر وفي اشياء ممكن ما تمر
لانه تخص المراه لكن اي هذا كان رايي وكان
ودائما احس انا بالسناب شات يعني مكاني
الخاص بيني وبين متتابعين اللي يحملون نفس
مبادئ ونفس ارائي ونفس افكاري لو جيد انك
تطرحي وجهه نظر في وسط يعني كمان وجهات
النظر المتداوله يعني بنسبه معك وفي ناس
[موسيقى]
بتكلم عن كنت انه يعني العجاله في الحكم
على المسلسل
احنا تونا اليوم في سبعه رمضان يعني
الاحداث الي جايه بالمسلسل راح تكشف
الكثير الكثير
من الاشياء اللي راح تنصدمون يعني انا
يعني اقول حق المشاهدين والمتابعين انه
راح يشوفون شيء جدا جميل راح يشوفونا
الاستاذه ليلى واحنا بنتكلم انا معاها
راحت رمت لي قنبله عن الاحداث جايه قلت
لها ليه يا ليلى انا بتابع المسلسل يا
ليلى ليه ليه ليه
خربتيه الدنيا يعني
طبعا يعني انا والله شوفي انا انا سعيده
طبعا بالمشاهده الذويق يعني وطبعا استانس
لمن اشوف في حاله من من اثاره الجدل
واثاره الجدل يعني اثاره العقل
الحلو ان الناس لما تتناقش وتشوفوا بس
دائما يزعلني سرعه الحكم سرعه انت يمكن
كمان تحديدا خلينا نكون صريحين اكثر ليله
بتحكي على موضوع الكثير ناس اتهموكم في
موضوع الاساءه للمراه العراقيه
طبعا اكيد يعني
طبعا لان مثل ما قلت لك احنا بالنهايه
يعني فنانين نحمل رساله سلام واحنا الناس
جدا مسالمين وبترك انا بقيه الابابه
للاستاذه هبه مشاري حماده ايوه
اتكلمت اكيد يعني راح يكون في توضيح اكثر
ومثل ما قلت لك انا اخاف اني اتكلم واحلق
الموضوع لا لا خلاص كفايه الله يخليك الله
اتبع المسلسل خليني انقلك على كذبه ابريل
مختلف تماما دور كذبه ابريل
الحمد لله انا كنت خايفه من هالنقطه يعني
كنت دائما
مضاوي ورزان يكونون يعني مختلفين علشان
الناس انا يعني كنت ادري ان الناس راح
تحبها المسلسل وراح تحب هالمسلسل فكنت ابي
ان الناس تشوف ان هذا غير وهذا غيره الحمد
لله يعني صابت
كذبه ابريل يعني كذا في دراما اللي هي
بتصير يعني مثلا ان العوائل والاشياء هذه
كله وفيها الموضوع قديش الرجال كذاب
واناني واشياء من هذا النوع بتشوفي بتتفقي
مع هذا الموضوع انه الرجال كثير كذاب
وقناني
الرجال كثير كذاب واناني يعني طبعا
بعد العالم ما يخلى يعني من
الانانين وقلت لك هذه قصه موجوده يعني مو
الكاتب هم لمن قال ياها قال لي انه هو
استوحاها من المجتمع
مسلسل طبعا ساره مثل ما لاحظتي ان كل سنه
انا اطلع بعملين عمل جريء وعامل يعني
يناسب
على هذه السيره ايوه انا كنت بدي اسالك
يعني السنه الماضيه من شارع الهرم الى
يعني كسرت الدنيا ما تركت احد ما اتكلم عن
العمل وحتى انت وقتها كان عندك دور
وهاجموكي وقالوا انه لانك طلعتي على
الميزان وقالوا انك انت لابسه مع انه ما
كان باين الا رجولك من تحت يعني ما في شيء
صاير في هذا الهجوم على وقتها على هذا
العمل وعلى علاقتك مع زوجك في هذا العمل
وكذا ايش يعني
ضايقك وقتها
شوفي وقتها كان ضايقني لان يعني انا كنت
ابي تكون المعركه معركه مرض مرض البوليميا
معركه انسانيه مو معركه جسد ولا معركه
يعني
فكره
مبتذله على قولتهم يعني انا انسانه جريئه
ولكن مو مبتذله وهناك فرق كبير بين الجدل
والابتدال دائما يصير في ايه يعني دائما
يصير في بين الاثنين لا واكيد انت في
المشهد يعني رجولك اللي بانت الحقيقه يعني
هذا موضوع قديم وتعدينا وتخطينا منه وانا
دائما يعني مثل ما قلت لك اقدم عملين عمل
يليق بالناس اللي تحب انه تشوف
يعني شلون اشرح لك
بليفل معين وعمل لي انا ليلى الفنانه اللي
يبي اوصل يكون لصيت بالعالميه فاللي حاب
يشوف هني اللي حاب يشوف هنيه ولكم حريه
الاختيار لا اكيد عامله العملين فعلا
مختلفين والاثنين عاملين يعني صدى رائع
جدا ليلى انا دائما احب اتكلم معاكي
ودائما يعني سعيده بظهورك معنا شكرا لك
اليوم حبيبه قلبي وان شاء الله نرجع نشوفك
على في دبي الحق نفطر ولا نتسحر
تسلميلي كانت معنا الفنانه ليلى عبد الله
شكرا لك يا ليلى شكرا يا حبيبتي شكرا